all right the uh the hot dog pizza has
arrived do you know how much it was
we've received about 2 200. [ __ ] 22
bucks for a pizza this size look at this
oh it's it's 50 off though this was 20
thanks japan thank you [ __ ] what what
a joke look at that
oh my god it's like actual like sausages
yeah bro dig in all right digging on
what kind of pizza is it just a normal
margarita no it's a pepperoni yeah give
me a slice there we go you're not going
to tell me that this is better than
stone baked oh there this is bro okay to
be fair i can't moist that i'm not i'm
not a massive fan of pizza hut pizza in
japan no the pizza it's this okay this
this one in japan is weak bro yeah it's
not great but i am curious to see how
this uh
yeah how this sausage is going to fare
hmm that's pretty good actually yeah
i mean pizza is pizza so it's going to
taste good no matter what um i just have
that thick cheesy taste you know that's
thick bread um
i like how we're just eating
what do you only listen is i apologize
what point were we trying to prove again
the hot dog i mean when you get to it
try it okay and then like wrap it up a
little bit get some sauce i just eat it
first i feel like it's going to taste
less good than that pizza side i've got
a bit of sauce left some cheese on it
[Music]
it's such a honey pot it's a hot dog i
love it
okay i [ __ ] with this right isn't it
good it's weirdly good right
i mean i've had this before it shouldn't
be this good like i normally get dip as
well oh but is this is this better than
stuffed crust yeah i think so i think
it's better than stuff crosstalk they're
so good
i love that i don't like the cheese
they're using stuffed crust
really yeah it's too like um thick yeah
it's weighted and it's like it like it
tastes like very similar so you just get
like a lot of cheese like way too much
no yeah you have to have like the fresh
stuffed crust because when it's starting
to use this later when it starts please
try give us your verdict give it a go
give us a go sausage we need a second
opinion on this when it starts to harden
a bit that's when stuff crosses i don't
like stars why is it why is it like
outside well normally sometimes it's
inside but i like it i think it's good
yeah yeah i want sydney's voting because
an american
yeah sydney what's what's your verdict
as an american sydney let's try it
well just eat this just just eat it how
you normally would and then when you get
to the cross just like leave a little
bit of the pizza yeah and then just go
from the side grunge like left on his
pizza can you please oh we did it later
i died [ __ ] you
i'll finish it later who just leaves the
pizza for america
i'm not american but god damn sometimes
i wish i was like maybe that's why i'm
so angry about them all the time because
i i just want to be an american maybe
i wish he was angry at something he
can't be i just i wish i could be
american honest opinion well it's an
option i mean it's fine with dip it's
way better like maybe
when you get some dip on it man
oh yeah is it optional
if you put something like if you put
some ranch on that [ __ ] oh my god bro
it's different oh
yeah right but normally no i'd rather
cheese in a crust okay okay yeah i would
i would prefer cheese in the crust as
well it's like you get a pizza and then
at the end you're like oh [ __ ] you get
like a little meal at the end yeah okay
i like it i like it i never i'd never go
to a restaurant and look look a waiter
in the eye and be like can i have the
option with the hot dog in the class but
if i can if i can call up a pizza place
and tell them hey can you send it with
the cr for some reason
i think i've figured out your taste
which is you need some like variety in
it you can't just have like even if
something tastes amazing you can't just
have that same thing i mean i i can eat
bread like straight up just say that
except for bread apparently yeah it's
it's like two ends of the spectrum
there's either no variety or too much
variety this is what half and half is
amazing as well like i love half and
half like who doesn't want half and half
i don't know one half i don't like half
and half i don't like why would you not
want like two different flavors because
because why not why not just order the
superior flavor yeah and just stick on
the two flavors are amazing and i want
to experience both
one one flavor is always the best so i
ordered that flavor yeah and that's all
i need because
i agree because because like because if
you have half an hour half and half
never very rarely never by choice it's
always at a party right because you need
variety at a party right yeah but like i
often find that halfway through a pizza
especially a heavy one i kind of need
something else to kind of mix it up so
that i'm not tasting just the same same
same but that's what dip is for right
yeah well different i mean i love dip
too when i have pizza i want like every
dip on the table like yeah and i'm like
dunk dunk exactly well for me if i have
the same thing but it's an amazing same
thing then i can just eat that endlessly
until i'm sure but because pizza is like
that style of pizza we just had is quite
heavy like getting four or five slices
of that in you're like all right i need
a chicken no it's not
stone baby yeah yeah yeah but i'm not
i'm not saying that stone baked is is
like
better it's like god was waiting for
them
pizza into one into like one little ball
it's like one slice of a normal american
pizza and dinner what
do you fold up your pizza into a bowl
can we do that
can we roll up a stone-baked pizza into
a bowl and just like take a bite out of
it it's like kind of wrap it around yeah
yeah it's just like turning it's like a
dim sum yeah yeah like a dim sum yeah
it's like wrap it around
i'm just speechless i think i actually
got the italian mafia on me for saying
that you just lost any right to go to
italy yeah i can't i think we've all
lost some sort of right to some sort of
uh
i mean yes you have yeah yes you are
yeah you have definitely really just i'm
pretty sure you just declared war
against italy i'm i'm willing to give
credit where credit to italy you know
create away credit is due to italy like
like they were the ones that kind of
came in and was like you guys have it
good he's all right right i'm sorry i'm
a british man
all right here about hit me out right
let me out here the italians are gone
coffee they're doing that right
they got something right you know
all right they got that on lockdown no
no one can even pretend to have like any
claim over there
okay yeah so like okay for example right
like american pasta is like a little bit
different to like the standard italian
pasta right italian pasta is like
[ __ ] drenched in uh sorry uh um
american is like [ __ ] heavy it's like
so much sauce like it's a lot of oil
yeah okay i don't [ __ ] with that that's
just too much yeah it has a time in
place yeah yeah like like a magiano's is
like every now and then i'll go there if
i want to feel like i want to destroy my
stomach yeah like i understand how olive
garden can do like bottomless of stuff
like oh it's the way they do bottomless
bread down there yeah it's bottomless
breast sticks yeah that's true which is
like the bird sticks aren't even that
good
it's like i don't want bottomless or
something that's mid would you have an
entire an entire meal of breadsticks
it depends how good the best breadsticks
are good
not olive garden bread sticks though no
that's just like bread flavored
cardboard
sorry i'll have gone but
i'm just i'm just wondering like when we
ordered um we ordered uh it was napoleon
style pizza from around uh not too far
away there's a few chains of them around
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and it was awful oh yeah
really [ __ ] it wasn't that great they're
so bad yeah well i mean it's japan right
and i don't even know
like that was going for like stone baked
but not stone baked that was a really
weird hybrid remember that it was like
it looked like it looked like a stone
bake but it didn't taste like it was
actually yeah
yeah
it's like it's like it looks stone-baked
but here's an oven
a lot of pizzas i find don't have a very
discernible cheesy taste and i l i want
to be able to taste the cheese right
yeah same that like a lot of pizzas
either either because that's also when
you put too much topping on the pizza
yeah yeah like you can't taste anything
because you taste like meat it's just
like too much i need to taste all the
flavors in unison yeah yeah
so like
there needs to be like a right ratio of
like crust yeah sauce and cheese and
toppings as well yeah exactly
otherwise otherwise get there are some
pizzas i see where like
it's basically just you know cheesy
bread and
i know that's a type of pizza i'm gonna
get a pizza that's just cheese right oh
and you can also get margaritas and
cheese pizza yeah which is just which is
just uh sauce yeah yeah well i don't i
don't understand the [ __ ] with that yeah
i don't [ __ ] with that i don't get that
i guess that's if you're like i want to
have a pizza but i don't i don't feel
too bad about it it's like the people
who get a pizza and they just scrape the
toppings off right now that hurts that
actually i'm like what happened to you
in your childhood yeah just like just
get a pasta
i die a bit inside every time i see you
just like dunk your bread in some pasta
sauce like just bring like
just bring like a [ __ ] pasta like one
of those sauce pots with you like
why ruin some pizza like don't do that
this is not how i intended the new year
for to start by the way i did not think
i'd be honest i intended to start this
it's not trash taste without an argument
about food like i i don't know
who had the most clown opinion this
episode
no ninety percent of bread tastes the
same all rice tastes the same bro come
on italian pizza american american pizza
everyone was a clown today ladies and
gentlemen
was a clown i'm glad we called this
trash taste it shields us from a lot of
criticism oh yeah let's just say that
yes because we say something
you can say all you want guys but we're
trash days
what did you expect i i like how we made
the name in preparation of us having
like shitty anime takes and like none of
us intended to ever talk about food
online right everyone is so scared to
give their like genuine opinions on
stuff yeah